[Music]
all right we have talked
about a lot of homes like there have
been many stories
that we've discussed here on this
channel about homes that have
like horrible conditions where people
actually live in and stuff oh like the
haunted house
haunted house that's a horrible
condition or dirt floor
dirt floor on the second story yeah or
like
plumbing where the whole place is
flooded with diarrhea yes
or like a home that has corpses will the
airplanes just flooded with diarrhea
what happened i had it called a plumber
well see he fixed it
he's like ratting out his own home he's
like oh those gross houses where the
diary is going everywhere like
no you're right and it's your diarrhea
so you step in it the diarrhea came out
of the bathtub
hole what i know right it wouldn't
[ __ ] drain and i'm like what's
happening dude
that's so gross yeah bathtub no
like you she took a shitty in the shower
[Laughter]
no um and then you know usually if you
you know that drain part on the top yeah
you unplug that you plug it
yeah so then the air doesn't go out and
then you get a plunger and you [ __ ]
go like this and you can clear the clog
but i went like this right and then
more water started coming down
and now he's showering himself with it
cocka stuff came out spinach
like garbage just all kinds of [ __ ] came
out i was like what's happening dude oh
[ __ ] i look at the toilet the toilet's
like draining and i'm like how's the
toilet connected to this
drain it's like ear nose and throat
on top of that dude i went to the
kitchen and the [ __ ] kitchen
sink started flooding with cocka [ __ ] oh
god i know isn't that disgusting that's
what i'll wash my dishes
there i would have burned that place
down even though it's not mine so is
this article about joe's house
yeah i had to call a plumber i couldn't
do it myself
and then the plumber they did the snaky
thing and they're like oh no something's
stuck
and then they pulled out a [ __ ] rag
dude
like somebody threw away a rag in the
toilet didn't you live by yourself
flushed it yeah but that's not me
there's no way i flushed that
dumb one flush this rag that says joe
an island like a towel yeah a towel
yeah but then it flooded too where the
washing machine was
and so like some fans were saying that
sometimes
rags and socks and things can get sucked
through it
and then it gets stuck on the pipe so
that could be the case
or somebody just [ __ ] wipe the toilet
and say oh
and it flushed the toilet or something
do you think it
that's what it is no the rag was like it
was a white rag that was completely
black
how do you know it was white it was like
you could tell that it used to be
like there's marks on it that was like
yeah yeah but it was
completely i watched it afterwards
it was disgusting dude
it was so bad yeah but after that it was
like all right things started to drain
did you actually have it like on your
floor like your bedroom floor was filled
with kaka and [ __ ]
no uh thank god it didn't flood just it
just
sinks in all this jinx and it was a
drink yeah but then i had to uh
the kitchen sink i had to get a [ __ ]
pot and a bucket
and because it kept overflowing because
the kitchen seat oh
it was gonna [ __ ] float on the ground
yeah so i had to get that [ __ ]
because the water kept going up it was
so
you were alone running around your whole
house trying to like make sure yeah
because this was like at night and then
so i was like it's like whack-a-mole
he's like yeah i had to get the kitchen
sink
down as low as possible so i could go to
sleep and wake up and it was still
flowing up so i timed it right enough
yeah and then the uh
mr mr plumber guy came and then he
hooked
everything up yeah massive [ __ ] like
the snake thing it looked like some
crazy generator that they were gonna use
for like war
wow it was like this [ __ ] big and i
was like what'd you do with all the [ __ ]
it drained are you just draining it it
drained it and then i had to get like
[ __ ] bleach
i had to get like i disinfected the life
of everything dude
good yeah i did that and then i got a
[ __ ] sponge with some dish soap and i
went all over and then i got some
[ __ ] uh like the clorox powder and i
just left it there
yeah i had man my all the there's so
much chemicals in my drain
now [ __ ] there's no way it's got kaka
damn
well i don't know how you're going to
fix this problem
because uh recently this russian
woman she went to authorities for help
because
her mother had been hospitalized and
that was the first time that this woman
finally left her house for the first
time in over in
in 26 years she never left the house in
26 years quarantine her mom yeah her
name is quarantina
yeah so her mom her mom was super
over protected like apparently she did
this to protect her from the world
bubble girl yeah but it's kind of
twisted because their home was
disgusting they had they have cats
everywhere
and cats would die rats would die and
they wouldn't move the corpses
hoarders cat hoarders they're saving it
just in case they might come back to
life
my cat was rescued from a cat hoarder
yeah there were 50 cats in like a
trailer
whoa that must be fun for the cats
and then they all got like ffiv or flv i
can't feline
leukemia yeah because they were sharing
litter boxes
they're all balding do they get chemo is
that what happens
no but they only last for they only live
for like two years but my
my cat did not it was one of the two
that didn't get it
two out of fifty whoa which one joe or
franklin him and his sister oh cute
okay so back to this one i have a video
of
where they're walking through the home
and
the daughter said that the last time she
showered was in 2006.
what the [ __ ] because they live they
live in a home without electricity
no running water no running water
then where do they crap
on the floor outside well they won't
have your problem
yeah there's no pipes no pipes to flood
yeah and then apparently there were
reports saying that the mom would force
the daughter to eat cat food
and that the daughter was like sobbing
abusive
exactly so abusive to the point where
she said my life is worse than a cat's
life cats have more rights
i don't even exist anymore i'm the
living dead so
wait wait she she had to go the daughter
finally left the house because of why
because her mom had to get hospitalized
for something i don't know
so that's the first time they both left
the house pretty much
yeah so she's saying that the daughter
she used to go to school and stuff but
then at the age of 16
she like the mom no longer let her go to
school she wasn't able to pursue
a career or anything and
it was just like the daughter said like
eventually she just gave up
on trying to leave and so she just
stayed there
when the mother was taken into the
hospital that's when she was like oh
[ __ ] i'm free
like i can finally do something with my
life and but
they're saying that she's afraid to make
too many changes in her life
so she fears that she will not be able
to understand how the world works now
somebody give her some dick
first things first cause damn dude i
kind of want to know
what she smells like she probably
showered dude
you know it's a trip she's 42 years old
but you're going to see how young she
looks
like whoa in those conditions
yeah here we go
[Music]
i remember
you see that her hair that's her hair
yeah oh i don't want to smell it anymore
this smell it looks like it's like bad
is she telling the kitty don't do that
katie those are dead cats yeah these are
oh my god
what the hell she's not ashamed look at
her face she's like
that's life she kind of she kind of
looks like she looks like a cat
so that's what they cut off of her head
whoa
that's a cat too she's probably got a
dead cat in there there's a cat that was
stuck on her head
damn poor girl dude i know
poor lady crazy what would you do what
would you do first
now you're free what are you doing dick
dude yeah you haven't you haven't left
you haven't been in the outside world
since 1994. 94.
that's 26 years 1994. that's 26 years
ago
i'd take a nap on some clean linen oh
well first i take a nice ass bath but
i'm gonna need somebody to help me
because i probably don't know how to
take a legit bath
so i need ten servants like an egyptian
fan
is this leading to it no no i'm gonna
get dick afterwards oh okay
so first because i got to prep this
[ __ ] to
get some good essence like there must be
a dead cat down there
you gotta you gotta pull the [ __ ] apart
because it's probably stuck together oh
that's true it's petrified [ __ ]
dude yeah how did she deal with her
periods so maybe maybe the whole spot
treatment you need a doctor
you need masseuse you need a mechanic
maybe
a mechanic you need a [ __ ] makeover
artist you need jeffree star you need
all that [ __ ]
congeniality team yeah there we go and
then
she gets her thing and she's like oh i
feel like a brand new person kind of
looked like sandra bullock before miss
katie
yeah dude that is that is your
cinderella story right here man
poor woman man do you have a after
picture she looks all fine oh that'd be
sick
wait if they don't have electricity in
their house do you think that
she has like what cognitive
understanding of the outside world that
she has exactly that's what i was
thinking how does she know about like
school or whatever
so she got trapped there when she was in
her 20s if she's 46
right she was 16 yeah she was 16. she's
42 years old
yeah she said 2016. left the house for
26 years the last time she
showered 20 2006. so it's 20.
so oh so 16 she was pulled out of school
that's that's what it was
so she was able to leave around but then
since 20 years old she hasn't left that
house
well this is what it exactly says it
says tatiana which is a mom initially
prevented the daughter from leaving the
house at the age of 16 but eventually
she got used to not being able to leave
and stop trying to oh so
yeah oh she got defeated then by her mom
that was the
[ __ ] face of someone just completely
brainwashed
yeah she was just shocked yeah well
she's she is asking
like for help and she's asking uh for a
passport and a place to work
so she wants to work oh that's awesome
right i mean what can she do
she wants money she could probably i was
gonna say she could probably clean but
then i don't know
no yeah because that place looked dirty
oh you know what she could do she could
work at the shelter she has a lot of
like a cat cat experience what if she
could be like the cat
and they left them in the house i
wouldn't want her [ __ ] around my cats
that's true i don't think she was
killing them i'm not saying she was
killing her i'm just saying look at that
they're dead
but she might understand cats better
than any of us do because she ate their
food
excuse me she might speak cat oh okay
okay fair i'm not trying to take
anything from her it's not like she has
a lot to be taken from i'm just saying
if she's gonna work at a cat shelter in
a recent history she was
living with a bunch of dead cats it's a
weird resume but we could we could we
could we could teach her cleanly
yeah and hygiene yeah i think i think
the magic here is she
she has a talent that none of us do and
it's speaking [ __ ]
um yeah sure
that wasn't a fact but sure
you